what really launched my serious research
into network effects and the economics
of network effects but some of the work
that I was doing in human capital and
the notion that innovation isn't just a
transaction innovation is an investment
in the human capital and capabilities
and competencies and creativity of your
customers network effects are basically
how customers or users create value for
each other
it's basically an external to the
individual user so an example of a
network effect would be if you and I had
a phone that would be great for you and
I but a network effect is the more
people who use phones the more valuable
the phone network becomes the more
valuable each other become because we
can call more people and more people can
call us and heck there may even be the
opportunity to do a conference call
which is another form of network effect
so network effects are basically a way
that the more people participate in
using a product or service the more
valuable it becomes there's no such
thing anymore as a non networked
organization now admittedly some
networks are better than others but we
can absolutely make the case that one of
the fundamental transformations over the
last 50 years is the networked
efficacious of large organizations and
small organizations not just in osed
countries but all over the world network
ofin has taken over the world it's how
do you get value from these networks
there's a wonderful line from the first
industrial sociologist a Frenchman by
the name of Frederick Lee play he was
the superintendent of a call des mines
and his phrase was the most important
product of the mine is the miner it's
not the coal it's not the metal it's not
the tin
it's the human capital that allows you
to extract the value from the mind so
let's update this to the 21st century
the most important product of the
network is the network er not the bits
not the bytes not the bandwidth not the
data it's the people and in an Internet
of Things age the things the machines
the devices on the network if we can
make networkers more valuable we make
our networks more valuable and that is
indeed the recipe for an Amazon for a
Google for a Yelp for a LinkedIn for an
AT&T for a Netflix what does Google do
to make customers better it gives them
the ability to search and iterate on
those searches and what does Google do
it converts those clicks into more
efficient search that's the essence of a
web 2.0 network effects company the same
holds for the Amazon recommendation
engine or for Netflix so what you're
doing is you're making it and you're not
just giving customers what they want
you're investing in improving their
capabilities what was another way that
Google did that Google gave you for free
gmail email which enables it to learn
more about your social network what
you're interested in communicating about
etc same thing with LinkedIn so the
whole notion that's why a LinkedIn
bought a company like Linda so not just
to improve people's resume but to
improve people's skills so the the
notion of a network effect here is as we
give our customers the ability to do
more for themselves they can do more
with us and on our network so in the
early days of the telephone all you
could do is talk to someone then you
could do a fax then you could do a
conference call then there were these
things called modems that allowed you to
send email you are increasing the
capability of the customer allowed you
to get more value from the network and
indeed customers wanted to do so much
you had to do what
to redesign the architectures and the
capabilities of the network so you have
an iterative network development process
here as customer capabilities and
capacities increase you have to change
the capabilities and capacities of the
network and vice versa